omar garcía es sobreviviente del caso
ayotzinapa la desaparición de 43
estudiantes con la complicidad de la
policía ha estado viajando para promover
la consulta popular que se hará en
mexico para que la población decida si
se deben esclarecer hechos del pasado y
procurar justicia
todo lo que hemos hecho en el caso de
china hay otras personas
en otros casos siempre ha sido con el
objetivo de abonar sabemos que una
consulta popular no es definitiva ni
definitoria son pasta más es una forma
de agrietar el muro de la impunidad
popular la pregunta original impulsada
por el presidente lópez obrador era
consultar si se enjuicia expresidentes
aunque de hecho no tienen inmunidad tras
la polémica la corte cambió la redacción
y la enfocó en el esclarecimiento de
decisiones de actores políticos del
pasado pero la pregunta quedó difusa
y otras víctimas y una parte de la
sociedad no están muy de acuerdo con la
consulta es el caso del poeta y
activista javier sicilia cuyo hijo fue
asesinado
la justicia
no se pone a discusión la verdad no se
pone a discusión al parecer de la gente
es la condición del estado la vida del
estado y la exigencia de una nación
defensores de derechos aprovechan el
contexto para señalar que más que
enjuiciar a expresidentes se necesitan
comisiones de la verdad y mecanismos de
justicia transicional detrás de la
pregunta de la consulta está el derecho
a la verdad el derecho a saber que
tenemos todas las personas las víctimas
por supuesto pero la sociedad en general
a saber qué pasó la mayoría de la gente
se quedó con la idea del juicio
expresidentes pero la consulta en sí
divide opiniones y para que sea replante
necesitan participar 37 millones de
mexicanos